three years ago I started building a
decent rised
web because I was worried about the
future of her Internet the correct
Internet - I use it about gatekeepers if
you want to read something on the web
then you need to go to multiple
middleman
first a domain name reserver then a
server hosting company which usually
points you to a third party to the web
hosting service and this happens every
time you want to reach a web site on the
bed but these gatekeepers are vulnerable
to enter the text and also makes the
censorship and the survelliance easier
and the situation is getting worse
everything moving to a cloud but the
data is hosted by giant corporations
this move creates much much more
powerful middleman now move to the cloud
makes sense because this way it's easier
and cheaper for the developers in the
service operators they don't have to
worry about maintaining the physical
servers I can't blame them but I found
this trend to be very dangerous because
this way these giant corporations has
unlimited control over the hosted
services and it's very easy to abuse
this power for example last year a CEO
of a campaign that acts as a gatekeeper
for 9 million web sites decided after
some public pressure that Valve decides
it manages of 4 right page should be
blood didn't send an internal email to
his coworkers this was an arbitrary
decision I woke up this morning in a bad
mood and decided to keep them off the
internet even he admits no one should
have this
power as a response one of the employees
asked him is this the day the internet
dies I don't think we are actually
killing the internet but I do think that
we are in the middle of a kind of
irresponsible centralization process
that makes her internet more fragile the
decentralized people-to-people web solve
this problem by removing the central
points the web hosting services it
empowers the users to have Haas sites
they want to preserve on this network
the site got down on the directly from
other visitors this means if you have a
site with wanted visitors then it's
hosted 100 computers around the world
basically this is a people powered
version of the Internet the security of
the network is provided by public key
cryptography this makes sure that no one
can modify the sites but only the real
owner think of it like instead of
getting activity from big power plants
you put solar panel on top of your hubs
and if your neighbor down the street
needs some extra energy then they can
just download some from your house so by
using the decentralized web we can have
to keep content accessible for other
visitors and by that it means that we
can also fight against things that you
feel unjust like censorship in China the
Internet is tightly controlled they can
criticize the government organized
protests and it's also forbidden to post
channel emoticon to remember the victims
that the animals were massacre in the
distant reserve it's not the government
that decides what gets seen and what
doesn't is the people which makes the
web more democratic
but at the same time it's hard to use
this network distribute something that
is clearly illegal everywhere in the
world as the users probably don't want
to endanger themselves hosting these
kind of periodic content another
increasing threat to Internet freedom is
over-regulation I have the impression
that our delegates revolves on the
internet regulation laws are not fully
aware decisions for example the European
Parliament has a new law on the table a
new copyright protection law that has a
part called article 13 if it passes it
would require every big website to
implement a filter that automatically
blocks contents based the rules
controlled by big corporations the
original idea is to protect copyrighted
materials but it would endanger many
other things we do on the internet
blogging criticizing discussing linking
and sharing the Google and YouTube are
already has similar systems and they
receiving 100,000 take the request every
our of course they can't process the
sound of data by hand so they using
machine learning to decide if it's
really a copyright violation or not but
these filters do make mistakes they
removing everything from documentation
of human rights abuses lectures about
copyrights and search result that points
to criticism of this new article 13 and
beside of that they are also removing
many other things and sometimes these
filters you're just removing the
specific content but it could also lead
to loss of your link at accounts your
email address your documents your photos
or your unfinished book which happened
with the writer Dennis Cooper it's not
hard to see how system like this could
be abused by politicians and corporate
competitors this article 13 the
extension of these outdated filters to
the whole internet what strong
opposition from Wikipedia github Mozilla
and many others including the original
founders of the Internet and the World
Wide Web
Vint Cerf and timbres Lee but despite
this strong opposition on the last
European Parliament vote two-thirds of
the representatives are supported this
law the final vote will be early 2019
the result is important but whatever
happens I'm pretty sure it will be
followed by many other similar proposals
around the world these kind of
regulations would be very hard to
enforce to a decent rise but as there is
no hosting companies the websites are
served by the visitors themselves I
started to build this network three
years ago since then I spent thousands
tens of thousands of hours on the
development why why would anyone spend
thousands of hours on something the
Taliban can freely copy rename or you
know sell well in my case one of the
reasons was to do something meaningful
during my daily regular job as a web
developer I did not had the feeling that
I'm working on something that had a
chance to be bigger than me simply I
just wanted to make my short presence in
this work to be meaningful last year
the Great Fire of China started blocking
this network I created this move
officially made me the enemy of their
government
supported internet censorship since then
it's been really game of cat and mouse
they make new rules on the firewall and
I try to react to it as fast as I can so
the users can keep post content and
create websites that otherwise would be
censored by the centralized Chinese
Internet my other motivation to create
this network was worried I feel that the
future of our Internet is out of our
control the increasing centralization
the proposed loves are threatening or
freedom of speech and by that or
democracy so for me building a
decentralized web means creating a safe
harbor a space where the rules are not
written by big corporations and
political parties but by the people
thank you
[Applause]